um so today the first talk we're going
to have is from david wenger
uh he is a developer at microsoft
and here is hi dave will how's it going
going very well i'm i'm always impressed
by that uh
lego collection you have in the
background there dave
do you do you ever uh just pick one off
the shelves and
take it apart and rebuild it or they
just build ones
live sometimes they fall off the shelves
and get rebuilt
but uh usually i try to be nice my kids
not so much
[Laughter]
now i mean same i love lego do you find
the
you know lego sort of helps you take a
break from programming
but still keep your mind active in a
sort of way of
uh you know programming in a way nice
and procedural there's always
instructions
or do you just like building random
things no i'm definitely not the random
builder
i'll leave that to the kids i'm
definitely uh follow the instructions
and uh i like to uh so
you know there's cars and stuff behind
me i like cars um
what i like about it is as you're
putting it together you can see
some of you're seeing how it works and
how it fits together and then of course
it's uh it's greater than its parts kind
of thing
that's the same thing i like about
programming so there's definitely
parallels
now you are talking to us today about
records
but i'm assuming it's not the old music
records there's something uh very
different
uh c sharp records right that's right
yeah and uh so can you maybe just give
us a hint before we start why would i
choose
to use records over classes and
instructs for instance
uh that's an interesting question uh
that's
kind of you know maybe what i'm gonna
answer but
yeah i think i think the uh scott kind
of
i won't say he stole a line from me
because i'm pretty sure i stole it from
him but i have used it before in talks
uh when he was talking about looking you
know one
level below what you understand i love
that idea that's what i do as well
and that's sort of how i approach
records
so for me it's not that much about when
you would use a record or a structure a
class it's what's more important is to
understand what a record is
under the covers so that you can make
that decision because it's always going
to be
you know dependent on what you're doing
i'm looking forward to this dave because
i've got questions of my own about
records for you but i'll leave that to
the end i think uh we'll go through your
talk so uh
the stream is yours take it away all
right thank you
no pressure following uh that wonderful
keynote but
uh hello thank you for tuning in uh my
name's dave
let's talk about records what is a
record
uh that's a tough question that i don't
know the answer to because
well i didn't prepare for this talk at
all um
no a record is a funny thing to define
because
in c sharp nine a record is another way
of defining a type
but in c 10 even that statement is not
true and a record is now just
a thing and it's another way to define a
thing but it's not really its own thing
and
what i think a record is and this is a
very well led to by williams question
which was completely unscripted i
promise
is a record is really just the
collection of its parts right it's it's
all the bits of record put together
that's what define it and
i've sort of put six uh of those
features i guess
uh on the screen there to me this is
what defines a record it's just a record
has these has these qualities
essentially
what's interesting about records or
about these qualities
is that five of these which i have
circled with a squiggly square
are not exclusive to records and so
like i was saying before one of the
really cool things about records is even
if you're never going to use them
by understanding how they work and
understanding
what the compiler does to achieve
recordness
you can bring some of those concepts to
your existing code
even if you don't use records or maybe
you will use records or maybe use
records and you'll take some of them out
so that's kind of what i want to talk
about and i'm just going to
barrel through here we go so the first
one up is
simplified declaration and as of right
now and
including c 10 which is coming out in
november
this is exclusive to records the only
way to get this
simplified syntax is to use a record you
can't put it on your own classes and
things there's lots of requests for that
but you can't at the moment
and what this essentially is well i mean
you can see there right it's a one line
declaration
it kind of looks like a type declaration
because it's public
something car right it's not a return
type it's a thing
it kind of looks like a constructor
because again it doesn't have a
return type but it does have brackets
and parameters so it kind of looks like
a method call right so it kind of looks
like a constructor
and it kind of looks like a type
declaration and it turns out
it's kind of those things in one that
numdor's
parameter there explodes out
and becomes a parameter of the
constructor and a property of
the class that this would generate and
that's really what a record is at the
end of the day a record is a different
way of defining a class and it has some
other behaviors but that's kind of where
it is
um now full disclosure if you know what
records are and how they work
that's a lie it's not a set we'll talk
about that later and there's a lot more
that gets generated with records it's
not just a one constructor but we'll
cover all of that
um but simplified declaration is
for me the sort of the quintessential
thing about a record i
love that you can define a class in one
line
and use it and it has properties and it
does what you need to do it's really
good for
you know data transfer objects those
sort of things those small classes
um i just have you know a file and put
20 records definitions in it's 20 lines
and you're done
so it's really nice and if nothing else
uh it's
was probably one of my favorite or
second favorite feature of them um
even though it's arguably the least
interesting but that's what a record is
essentially
so let's get going uh i said that
records was
a class and in c sharp 9 that's true in
c sharp 10 that's not true
so what you can now do or
well now if you're using preview
versions of vs and in future
is you can actually tell the compiler
what type of thing you want this record
to be so you can say public record
class car and that will generate a class
and of course
if you can say class well then you can
say struct and that will generate a
struct
and this is also why records aren't
really anything because a record is just
a class or a struct it's not a new
kind of type in.net
which it seems like it is at first but
it's not
it's just the features you know um
i just saw melissa's question about
david's room and i thought she was
talking about lego
uh yes if you ask questions on slider
that's what that qr code in the corner
is for
um okay so immutable back to records
uh records are immutable by default um
someone there's many people who disagree
with that statement
uh there's often i won't say heated
debates but there's discussions about
this
concept uh there's some in github on
like the docs page where
it says they're immutable by default and
people complain that they're not
on c-sharp discord hello everyone on
c-sharp discord
uh i say things like yeah they're
immutable by default and everyone says
no they're not
immutable is controversial
so let me let me talk about this when i
say by default what i mean
is that simplified declaration of a
record this one liner
if you define a record in one line like
that then
it is an immutable object guaranteed
the problem with immutability in records
is you can't essentially know
whether a record is immutable or not
there is nothing by definition that says
it's immutable
so this record definition right single
line
this is immutable this record definition
is exactly the same but it is not
immutable and from a consuming point of
view
you can't tell obviously you can look at
the source code and tell if you can look
at the source code well
that answers all the questions right but
if you are given
uh an instance of type car and someone
tells you it's a record that doesn't
mean anything right this record down the
bottom there
is a mutable record because it has a set
accessor on that property you can set
that whenever you like
so as i lied to you earlier that's not
how
the c compiler generates a record what
it actually generates
is an init accessor so this is a new
thing added in c sharp nine
four records but it works on any
property
it works on structs it works on classes
and what it does is it allows you to
define
a mutable sorry an immutable type
so one where you can't set properties or
the unit properties anyway
except you can set them in if you're
initializing an object and there's
essentially two ways to initialize an
object in c sharp
number one is the constructor whoops
that's the constructor there on the
screen thank you
so as you can see right in the
constructor there we're setting this num
doors property
but well we've said we can't set it so
how does that work well the compiler
knows that okay in the constructor you
can call the unit property
and it is very specifically in the
constructor you can't set an init
property
in a method even if the method is called
from the constructor like it is specific
the other initialization case which i
skipped to earlier
is object initialization so pretend we
didn't have the constructor
you can construct an object in c-sharp
like this you just specify those
properties
and c-sharp will let you the file will
let you
even though you're setting a property
because you're initializing
the um initializing object thank you
aaron
yes they did uh if you try and set the
property
the normal way then you get an error
because
the compiler cannot know or doesn't know
that you're initializing
an object kind of like i mean you look
at that and you're like well obviously i
am but you know what i mean
um so let's let's let's just dig
into that because fine that's
immutability it's easy to say yes
there's an internet accessor
but the interesting thing comes as i
said from knowing why
so this is sharplab if you haven't seen
sharp lab before sharplab is an
amazing tool it's a website written by a
lovely man just across the pond in new
zealand and what it does
is as i type out code over here
which i will do right now it is
compiling
my code into il and then it is
using sorry using the latest bits of
roslyn so c sharp 10 essentially
and then it is decompiling my code but
it is telling il spy which is the
decompiler
it's saying hey i wrote this code with c
sharp 1. so none of these
features are sort of available to il spy
as it's decompiling
so if we look at this record i've just
defined
what it does is it explodes out to well
here's our class
car and there's a bunch of stuff here's
our backing field for our property
here's our property and we can see it
has an internet accessor
right that's cool doesn't really tell us
much but okay
if i create a variable
of this type i can this is a bit weird
but i can
set the property even though it's also
set in the constructor
you wouldn't want to do it but you can
but you can see here
this is my object initializer right this
is what it compiles to it compiles to
create a car and then set the numdos
property
the compiler is allowed to do this
because it's
the compiler it knows right it trusts
itself if i paste this over here
i'm going to get an error so this is the
compiler enforcing hey
you've got an init property here right
it says here you can't just
do this so how does an internet property
work well if we switch to il
which is very scary scary and i don't
like doing so i won't do it again
but if we have a look at what this
really generates uh and actually you
know what i'm gonna
change this because it's too scary for
me
i'm just gonna make this a uh what do
you say number doors
going to do the old-fashioned way on a
class
which means i need to get rid of that
this is a class with an inner property
uh sorry i'll just go back to the c
sharp just to prove there's no magic
here so this is just got a field
property in an accessor we'll get rid of
all that
record junk if we go down the bottom
here's our properties here's a property
called num doors it's an int
now properties if you didn't know
they're really just get and set methods
under the hood
so i get says get them dollars and our
set
is set numbers so in il
right in a net dll there's no such thing
as in it it's a c-sharp compiler thing
uh an init is really just a set with a
hat on
and this is the hat it's a mod rack
i have no idea what that means and it
basically
annotates it with this type and then the
compiler knows
hey if something is annotated with this
type it's an init
property and so it doesn't let you set
it so
why is this interesting well there's two
reasons number one firstly
you can use inner properties in your
normal classes right you don't need to
use records to get this feature
that's pretty cool number two this type
is defined
in uh net right it's in net core
i don't know 3.1 or whatever if you're
not targeting dotnet 3.1
you can't use init properties you get an
error that says
hey there is no type called is external
in it and you look at that and you're
like what the hell are you talking about
well it turns out if you work out what
the compiler does
you can do this and go to public static
class is external limits
and i'm going to get rid of the ielts
computing
if you do that actually i'm not if you
do this
you can use inner properties if we look
down at our property here you can see
our mod rack
now if you were keen eyed this is
actually slightly different
before this said system private call
live in front of it
right that's where the type came from
now the type is coming from our assembly
so we just essentially put in part of
the runtime and uh
you know now we can use inner properties
everywhere it is a little bit tricky in
that you want to be careful making this
public because if you've got something
consuming you that targets 3.1 or
whatever but
good question graham good question
can you get a property by reflection set
it yes so this is the
the asterisks here for immutability in c
sharp
uh c sharp loves backwards compatibility
in fact so does all of microsoft
so we don't like breaking people so as
you can see this is a set
in il this is still called set num doors
you can set this in reflection uh a now
the good thing about that is it means
that a d
serializer will still be able to set it
so
you can use a record or you can have a
class with an inner property and if
you're deserializing it from json or
whatever
that's cool your inner properties still
work they can still be set
by the decompiler but also your
immutability still works
and so you know that you know no one
else can change this property
which is cool
so the one uh drawback if you like
to inner properties or not drawback but
there's a bit of a gap still within the
properties which
hopefully will be fixed in future and
that is around nullability so if i
define a class
and i have a nullable string address
then fine we can make that init property
you can only set it during
initialization
and that's it it's great but if i define
a non-nullable string
and i don't have a constructor then i
get an error because
nothing is initializing this property
which means its default value is null
but you've said it's not nullable but
you don't want to initialize it because
you want
the people to initialize it and they
can't set it like so it's it's all very
these kind of features kind of bump into
each other and there's a few ways around
it you can just have a constructor and i
mean that makes sense right if everyone
has to set a name then
have it in your constructor right the
other way around it if you're sure that
someone is going to set the name like
for example if you know your code and
you
know for sure this is only ever going to
be used when deserializing
um you know some input then
you can sort of work around the issue so
one way is to
assign it to null and then use the
exclamation mark which is the null
forgiveness operator
which is the compiler shut up and get
out of my way operator
and this will work and this just says
yeah look okay fine i've initialized it
don't worry someone will follow up later
and obviously you could just make it
nullable as well but that's a bit
annoying because then you've got to
you know check for nulls all the time so
what's coming
in c sharp 11 it it recently got cut
from c-sharp 10
sadly is required properties and i
mentioned this because this is just
going to make everything
so much nicer and it's really going to
fill in the sort of the
the complete picture here so with inner
properties
i can say this can only be set during
initialization
can't set it anywhere else with required
i can say this has to be set
during initialization and so that really
completes the picture and then you can
really create classes
that you can control how they're used
fully when would i use an init property
over a record
i will leave that question until the
last slide
thank you aaron
value semantics so value semantics is
the next property we're going to talk
about next
property shouldn't use property it's
really hard to talk about types and
kinds and classes and objects
value semantics is the next feature
we're going to talk about
uh what is value semantics
good question uh what does this code do
right what is result
is it true or false right who knows no
way of knowing
um value semantics will submit
the semantics that we're talking about
here is what does it mean for one thing
to be equal to another thing
i'm going to switch to visual studio for
this one
which is over here so
feel free to yell at me producers if i
need to zoom i will in fact a little bit
later
so i have a different type of record
here called the point
and uh i've constructed a point it's got
two properties x and y right pretty
boring uh i'm actually going to make
another points though
and i'm going to set it to the same
the same values and then when i do
equals here
so that's p1 equal p2
and i run my code and i look for the
console window
hello contour window there is that's not
the right one
um oh there it is sorry that took a
while
so yes what can i say um so that
output's true
right those two points are equal because
they point to the same
point if i change one it's now false
great
make sense if i make this
a class not a glass but a class
and i run this it's still false
right so why isn't this
why was it true with a record and why
was it false with class well that's
value semantics so records
have no sense of equality of themselves
they
they sort of pass that on to their
constituent parts
um the real answer here is that um for a
class
the default equals does
uh
the default uh equality for a class is
reference equality which means is this
literally the exact same instance
right so what a record does
is it does value equality
the value equality means yeah these
represent the same thing they're still
not the exact same instance right that
second check still returns false
but they mean the same thing now if
you've used
structs before structs also have value
equality
so and this is another thing where
records get weird right what's a record
well it's a class well except it can be
a struct
what's cool about records they have
value equality but so destructs
but records can be structs so they
already have it
it's kind of weird and this is kind of
why i didn't want to answer the when
would you use question because
it depends so if a struct has value
equality i can achieve value equality
now
great uh if a record has value equality
i can use that to get it what about a
class well it turns out you can actually
value a quality very easily
you can just override the equals method
here
and i can say return
now i get to type on camera while making
lots of mistakes uh and
p x equals x i'm just gonna
describing oh look thank you intellicode
oh yep
you compile oh i missed pickles
no one in chat is yelling out equals i'm
shocked so
i've just made this class have value
equality
so what's so good about records right
like this is where you have to uh you
have to pick and choose what you're
using
why would you want to do it well so
valuable quality is really good
in some circumstances for example a
point class
it's pretty uh well it's obvious but it
might be
common that we don't
care what instance is what we just care
where is this point in physical space
and so that's what value equality
provides
right and so you can achieve all these
things but again it's just
a cool thing to know so now the question
becomes
or rather back to here whoops nope wrong
one
there we go so value semantics so
classes have reference equality but you
can implement value
equality if you want structure value
equality
records act like structs which is good
so why would you use records well it
turns out
records are better at being struck than
structure
so this is a benchmark.net output thingy
and so this is just calling the equals
method and a record
uh the equals method take took 20
nanoseconds i think this had two in
properties it was basically the point
class i had
and a struct took 340 nanoseconds now
that's a very short amount of time and
104 bytes allocated is not a lot of
memory
but sometimes people can care about
these things
and if you do you might want to choose a
record so
how is this speed achieved well for that
we have to go back
to sharp lab and we go back
to making this a record and we go back
to c sharp and we look at
the equals method the equals method in a
record
is right here and it does a bunch of
rubbish but essentially it does
what i did in my class it says hey are
these two fields
uh equal and if i in fact add another
field here
uh private underscore new fields
we will see in the equals method
um at the end at start there is no let's
get hash code
sorry there it is we will see that it is
including new field in its uh in its
equality check
so a record will generate an equals
method
that checks every single field and
that's how it does it
equality right so it's the constituent
parts a struct on the other hand
and if we look at the source of.net we
can find this out so
all structs inherit from value type
which is confusingly a class but ignore
that
value types equals method happens to be
at the top of the file which is very
convenient for me
and if we look at what it does we get to
this line and
if you know what this line is you'll
know why it's slower right this is
reflection
and if you think about it this kind of
makes sense a struct
at run time has to work out right what
fields do they have okay let me
loop through them and and you know this
this gets the value of both fields and
checks the equals
like it's the same logic but this is
happening at runtime
working out which fields you've got this
is happening at compile time
generating an equals method so
records are sort of
i won't say they're cheating because
they're not but they're a form of code
generation and if you've looked into
source generators and if you know me you
know that i
love structures um that's one of the
advantages right is they can look at
your code and they can do things and
therefore it
can get faster results and with
expressions
uh this is good we're banning through
them hopefully there's lots of questions
waiting for me maybe please ask
questions
um all right with expressions so uh here
i am defining two cars a honda rest 2000
is a car with two doors
and a honda accord euro is basically the
same as a honda s2000 but with four
doors
now if you know cars you now know what
car i drive
it's not the convertible um so
uh what am i doing here like what is
this new with
rubbish so what this is doing is this is
now firstly it's setting a uh
setting a property which well hang on
isn't that illegal because of init
properties well it is but this is
another form
of initializing types and well it's kind
of the same form this is like an object
expression but with some other stuff
but so what this is doing is saying hey
here's an instance
of a car under s2000 take that
make a copy of it and give me a new one
but
set the num doors to four so it's still
initializing
our honda record euro object it's just
that as part of that initialization
we're going to get most of it from
the existing object right so
let's go back to here and we'll zoom the
browser as requested sorry
for not noticing earlier um
so what are we going to do so here we
are so we have a car
and everything and i'm just going to
see with oops with
doors now this one is a very silly
example because car only has one
property but let's just have a look how
it works anyway
uh scroll down here it is so
this is our with expression now it's not
very clear and you just have to trust me
on that but it is um
the way a with expression works is a
little bit more compiler magic where the
compiler gets to cheat so
you're not allowed to set the num doors
property in your code but the compiler
can set it in its code because
you know it's the compiler right so what
the compiler does is it makes a copy
of the car and then it sets the property
and then it gives you back the car you
want it now
these variable names get confusing
that's because the decompilation doesn't
know your variable names
um but so it calls this weird clone
method
right now so i did this before and i'll
do it again
if we copy the code here you'll find
this is illegal code besides the fact
that carbon exists
not only because we're setting the
property which is this error
but the name clone doesn't exist and
there's an end of
file expected and things just get weird
and that's because of this
right this is not c code
so what is this nonsense this is what is
referred to as an
unspeakable method so this is a method
that is
valid in il as a name but it's not valid
in c
sharp and so the compiler uses this all
the time
to generate things that it doesn't want
people to call in fact
you can see it right here in the backing
fields the same thing the backing field
of a property is unspeakable because the
compiler doesn't want anyone to be able
to get at it
so why don't we want people to get at
the clone method
well in order to maintain immutability
we have to know that there is a way to
make a 100
accurate copy of this instance right
uh we have if if the if the act of
copying changes something
then that breaks immutability so the
clone method
uh is down here it doesn't look very
interesting it just calls this
constructor
here's the constructor it just sets
fields uh in fact again if i can
i can add a field here as well
[Applause]
yep you'll see the
the new field is here as well so again
all fields get
generated into this but so this
what this means is that there is a a way
the compiler trusts
to clone a record and as soon as it
knows well okay if i can make a faithful
copy
and that means i can set some properties
and that means i can sort of maintain
immutability
but allow for it's not really
modification because it's always copying
but it allow for
i guess deriving new instances and so
that's what with expressions do
so the other thing with really
expressions are this is just
i love this you can nest them and it
makes for really expressive code so this
is actually from my
train game it draws a bunch of stuff on
the screen so i have a background and
when you mouse over things i want to
hover them so i can define the hover
background
and saying hey the hover background's
the same as the background it just has a
different color
and so then whatever i do with the
background i know hover background will
sort of inherit it
right it's not inheritance but you know
what i mean um
and same thing with the colors right i
want light blue but i want an alpha of
85 percent
um so it's really nice syntax once you
get to use it
with expressions are not exclusive to
records but they are exclusive to
things the compiler knows it can copy so
in c sharp nine
that means records and in c sharp ten
that means record structs
in c sharp ten it's also going to be
available on every struct which is
pretty cool
so every structure you might have out
there you can now use with expressions
and anonymous types so anonymous types
is another one of these things where the
compiler generates code since the
compiler generates all of the code for
them
it knows it can make a faithful copy
if we look let me
make a new anonymous type quickly
the anonymous type here it is
unspeakable names again
right um the anonymous type doesn't have
anything interesting it has an equals
method it has two string like there's
nothing here to clone but because the
compiler
generates well essentially all of this
code but it generates this constructor
the compiler is going to when user with
expression
it'll just call the constructor of this
type
pass in all of the properties from the
existing one except for
whatever you set on here unfortunately i
can't demo this because
um this version
uh t-rex i don't think sharp web
uh this version this branch is
up-to-date
and unfortunately the the master build
of uh roston is currently failing
and um it's not my fault all right so
that's with expressions
fully customizable so this is the last
my last point
uh we're doing well time uh they're
fully customizable and so
i'm just gonna go back to here we've
actually seen this already
uh and we've seen this in basically
every
demo i've done let me get rid of all
this stuff
in fact here look i'm customizing a
record um
that sometimes gets confused there we go
what the compiler does is it wants to
generate a bunch of code for your record
he wants to generate a property and
what it does is for everything it's
going to generate it checks whether you
have first
so here it would want to generate this
numdos property sorry no it won't
wait a minute now it wants to generate
another property
but i got there first so it's not going
to so if i
comment out my property here's another
property we get
if i don't comment out my property
but we still get it but this is mine now
you can't tell because i've done it the
same way but if i change this to a set
and now this number property has a set
and so this is true of every part of a
record
so if you want to change how a records
tostring is
done you can just
you can just do this and you can go
whoops you see
and now when we look at the generated
code for a record
the two string method says return ndc so
you can take the bits of the record you
want
and if you want to change them then you
just change them what this means is
you can take this equals method
and you can put it here and you can
return false and now you don't have
value equality anymore right
um and so this is i mean you probably
wouldn't do that please don't
right but this is where records again
they get kind of weird right a record
could be a one line declaration that
does everything for you
or you could have a 3 000 line file that
has methods and properties and fields
and whatever else
any fields you define the compiler will
put in your records method any
uh properties the backing fields are
going right so you can
customize as much as you like
and so that goes back to the question of
you know when should i use a property
unit method well
what is a record right a record is
anything you like
it can be immutable and some would argue
that it's immediate by default
but it's also not necessarily it can be
really simple to declare
or you can declare it in a really long
verbose way it can have value semantics
or it cannot right
so what i like about a record is that i
get to look at how
the compiler team at microsoft who
writes c
sharp think a immutable class should be
written
and so i get to look at the get hash
code method and go what does this do how
does this work
more importantly i get to not write a
get hashcode method because i'm not
smart enough and i don't want my
dictionaries to break right
i get to take advantage of the things
from a record that i want but not
get the things that i don't want
on this though i strongly recommend if
you're going to do this
that you uh invest in
uh using sharp lab to uh
to have a look at what's going on i'll
give you an example of why
uh let's just make we're gonna make this
a record
that's to have an x and a y
uh and we're going to i don't know let's
just
we'll define one property and we'll let
the compiler define the other and we'll
try to
correctly use a cursor
so we have a we have a points got two
properties great
i'm initializing it to one and two great
so what should this output
you would think that it should output
one and two and it's just building
and it's going to be really slow oh
there it is
but it outputs one and zero so why is
that
so the danger of customizing is that the
compiler
might be doing things you don't know in
this case
uh it's because i never set this
property
now it's going to be one and two right
so
if you're going to customize it please
be careful
but you can
so it's kind of nice but it also you
know can be a trap
um the compiler does tell you here
there's a little green squiggle and it
says
uh that parameter y is unread so
that's nice um it just
it means that the the you shouldn't
necessarily
assume maybe that uh things are going to
keep working the way you want which is
again that's you know that's why i said
you can't tell a record is immutable
well in this case here's a record with
two properties you can't tell whether
the one is used or not
and i can't set this so this record's
just fundamentally broken this y
can never be anything but zero that's
not a good thing
um but anyway whoops hello you're still
on the screen
anyway i guess so records can be
anything
but what's sort of important
is that you look that one level
that one level below what's going on and
therefore you'll know what's going on
and
but you can take those bits you can take
the bits you want use them in the class
use them to
instruct you know change your existing
code maybe
i don't know it's up to you um and with
that
hopefully someone has some questions
because i
am done but i am pretty good for time
oh it's just me hello i have that's
fascinating dave there's uh
a whole lot to learn about the the
c-sharp compiler and and records there
um and we do have some interesting
questions actually
the first one comes from aaron powell
and he's asking
when would i use an init property over a
record
yeah i mean essentially this is up to
which bits do you want if you only want
in it properties then
you probably just want to use one and if
you want unit properties and
some of the other stuff records provide
then use records
and my dog agrees
you um yeah it really just is a matter
of i mean essentially
write down the pros and cons and pick
which column has the more things and
it's very much case by case
so now that's fair cool so
the next question is from harry asking
how does inheritance work with records
that's that for me that's an interesting
question as well what do you think yeah
so so inheritance is is uh it's
i didn't get into it because it makes
the code well it doesn't make the code
harder to understand
but some of the features of records are
the way they are because of inherit so
things like the clone method and things
like if you noticed when there was
a two-string method it called something
called print members that is there to
support inheritance and so
if i have a record that inherits from
another record then the two string of
the
outer one we'll call print members on
itself and then print members on the
inner one not two string on the inner
one so the output looks better
so there's a bunch of things around like
yeah with clone especially like with
immutability where they
the code they generate is specifically
to handle inheritance
so the answer to the question is it
works totally fine um
you can't inherit you can't inherit a
class from a record or a record from a
class
though well maybe you can arrest you
always have to okay it's really strong
from a record yes but it's exclusive and
again that's because of those
immutability guarantees right if you
could inherit from a class then that
base class could do anything you want
so um the next question from graeme
greene
i think you've already answered that
question before uh can you get a
property by reflection and set it
yeah that's the three issue none of this
none of this stuff is really sort of
run time um effect like there were yeah
there is a slight change to the runtime
four records which is that is external
in
type but yeah at the end of the day
these classes are just
plain old.net classes you can set
properties but then that's also true
with private setters and private fields
and private properties so
that's sort of not you know that's not
new right read only fields
same thing reflection right yeah you can
do what you want
but i think you know in some ways use
records because you sort of would prefer
the
generated code it's like you said uh or
showed the one benchmark it's a lot more
optimal
to use the generated code it's smarter
you know it's real code
cool so that sort of segues in the next
question when we
combine records with the width keyword
um and if you have a complex record for
instance it has
a dictionary or an i list a collection
and and you then with that add another
value to that
record does that complicated type or
complex type
get cloned exactly correctly yeah so
this is
this is uh yes
sorry no it doesn't um this is where
records
get uh a little bit hairy and in fact so
destruct right
um there's no deep cloning
ability like there's nothing baked
into.net right there
if there was the compiler wouldn't have
had to generate that clone method so
there is no way to know
essentially know how to clone a
dictionary right we can say i know how
to clone the dictionary because we
understand what the dictionary that's in
the framework happens to do but there's
no guarantees
you know someone else could write a
dictionary that does something different
so
no you're not going to get a deep clone
you're not going to get an exact copy
like that so you know you essentially
are copying a pointer to the same
dictionary across to the new
instance so you do need to be careful of
that you know you can't get
immutability out of mutable things
um that's you know that's just life
essentially uh this isn't
this isn't gonna reinvent the world um
so you do have to be a little bit
careful yeah
i wouldn't go i wouldn't suggest going
and changing all of your classes to
records just because you want to
you know i don't know i don't know why
you would anyway but uh you're probably
um but yeah so you do need to be a
little bit careful um they are
i mean the value equality thing is
it's you know what is the value of a
dictionary right
about when you compare two dictionaries
it doesn't compare every element
it doesn't i think and i think as dot
net developers we sort of understand
that that
that's different and so when you think
about well how would that work with
value quality well the answer is it
doesn't
right which i think makes sense but
maybe so
to so give a recommendation is if you
had a record
uh with an array for instance just a
simple array or something very basic
rather than a dictionary
that cloning would be more guaranteed or
more
you know correct yeah definitely if you
i mean
so this is sort of not i guess not
relevant to records really at all but
essentially if you're going for
immutable immutability
everything has to be immutable from the
ground up like you just
and and you certainly can achieve
immutability without records like the
internet accessor helps but
i mean you can do it traditional ways
right with constructors and private
setters
you don't get a with expression but you
can make with methods that do the same
thing
cool that's fascinating david
um thank you very much i think we've all
got a fair bit to
take away and learn from your talk
so thank you very much